all right an e.coli outbreak linked to
romaine lettuce is expanding this
morning the CDC now reporting cases in
23 states the number of people sick has
increased from 67 to 102 and that's in
just over a week our consumer
investigative correspondent and a Werner
is here and a good morning so where did
this problem begin well this all started
they say in California the CDC says
romaine grown in and around or near
Salinas California is likely the source
and it's telling consumers to throw away
lettuce that's either from that region
or unlabeled 58 people have now been
hospitalized with e.coli related
illnesses ten have developed kidney
failure no deaths have been reported
this particular ecoli strain is also
linked to an a 20-18 outbreak that
prompted a warning against eating any
romaine lettuce across the country so
how can you protect yourself well in
addition to avoiding Salinas grown
romaine the CDC says don't eat salad
mixes or wraps that could contain the
lettuce the CDC also warns that washing
or cooking romaine from Salinas will not
make that safe people usually get sick
three to four days after consuming
products tainted by this strain of
e.coli you should visit a doctor if you
develop symptoms including diarrhea
vomiting or a fever above 102 degrees
but I think it's worth pointing out to
people if you're in a restaurant you're
seeing romaine and they can't assure you
or you're not really sure if they really
know boy these salads
don't take a chance there and Fries
again for me you know yeah that wraps em
which comes with some lettuce and you
don't know whether it's romaine is
arugula okay I love arugula evidently so
I'm happy to say cuz I love it too